[Music]
hey arizona we in here
is that one yeah
hey [ __ ] thought it was a joke tell
her walk up on your door
knock
[Music]
[Music]
smart
[Music]
[Music]
muzzle on that [ __ ] before we park on a
[ __ ] i rather back him down
parallel park me a [ __ ] i hear you
coming for that power while i'm hooking
you [ __ ] turn on my goats
when i let the tommy talk to a [ __ ] yo
i let it bang bang bang like this was
[Music]
lot of z [ __ ] in the building shout
out tony chop shout out bullet cab
[Music]
last year being broke swear to god i
talked to jesus about it
you could be about it but it's all about
who you keep around it feet are sneaky
silent but don't come with happy feet
around me i know some people sleeping
but i still can't get no sleeping money
these [ __ ] bite your flows and get so
comfy
they can eat around it real prezi [ __ ]
this ain't no bush so i won't beat
around it
word better be good cause we can't go
off how your music sounded we should
take a silence cause every beat i get i
redesign it i'ma bring the best out of
my people
give em more and treat em equal [ __ ] i
look like asking for a fighting fear
about it
that's just perfect timing i think i met
some [ __ ] just so i could give them
some more guidance every diamond came
from mine and speaking minerals
i need em on my left hand and every
[ __ ] around me solid looking like a
best man i heard all of your verses i
just know i'm not impressed man i'm
coming for y'all heads could give a [ __ ]
about your vest dances vino
sometimes slower than when i was playing
on my [ __ ] a car
it's daily [ __ ] shark stop playing with
the kid
look hey yeah
i say which one of y'all [ __ ] gonna
take my spot you caught a buzz like one
song and now you thinking you hot
your [ __ ] said you got the juice and
now you thinking you packed
social distance [ __ ] moving you shot
changed my cars i like my clothes so i
switch up a lot
that's why i'm draping all this gucci
and i'm just leaving the dock
i wake up every morning count bands and
checking my stocks i came a long way
from selling pints to ducking from cops
yeah hey last time i check you [ __ ]
doing bad
they ask me what i am for halloween i
said in my bag
before this virus [ __ ] started my [ __ ]
then been wearing masks and snatch up
all your [ __ ] private throw that [ __ ]
in the back
you got it big difference between me and
you i'm talking two cars for a chains
and all these city views
crib out of glass event outside so i can
see it too
i got a vision these cartier's gonna
help me see it through [ __ ] saying we
[ __ ] they [ __ ] to me is nothing
new hey hey stop camo back shopping
cause i got options like foreign cars
said no big wheels and making profit
these [ __ ] going broke taking [ __ ]
can't get the logic
it's deadly [ __ ] let's go yeah hey
ways man that's why the records tap in
my [ __ ] gonna be let's go yeah i shout
out kev [ __ ] that [ __ ] easy
uh look i'm back in my bag and they're
waving the flat like they wait for the
next car taking shots at the same bar
eating cap y'all with a [ __ ] on pics of
a grandpa yeah that's cool
but look i'm cool enough i'm about to
soak up i need a new bra with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
most of ours had holes when life was
feeling good
i would wait for worse life ain't erased
then why was mama trying to make the
first
told me never quit till i stopped
breathing yeah she alive and she stopped
singing
so i gotta go a different route
flashbacks of when she fell and hit the
couch
everybody dreamed without a reason she
ain't live it out
i was the golden child till i questioned
god caught a couple cases then my family
went cold made me wanna cry
then it made me wanna die then it made
me wanna fight then it made me wanna
slide
almost caught a body mama stopped me
told me come inside put that knife down
look me in my [ __ ]
eyes new harshest was close when we was
doing well
i know heaven got a ghetto the proof is
hell
they want to see a few times before they
believe it but we don't gossip
but what you heard if you ain't seen it
when i got locked me and my mom and we
wasn't speaking and i still
check in every evening and i ain't gonna
get it till it's too late i'll focus
trying to get a plate
need a chill for me and regret
that's what i call them these [ __ ] did
it late know who tried to kill us we
took the jakes retaliator let that [ __ ]
live chose the ladder for a twist of
fate
could have stuck the ladder in the
chopper jeff and matt type of twist of
fate
making wild decisions trying to
demonstrate everybody hungry i ain't mad
that they did it in the name of
capitalism you gotta get it step on
somebody's neck and behead em to get the
chicken
them preachers telling lies we don't
speak for them cause angels got
favorites everybody don't die when a
reaper come
[Music]
man
keep it silent keep it private for the
fears keep a lawyer my attorney is the
smartest thing that [ __ ] went to whole
vegeta pick it lauren london book our
husbands who were important but they
both
cheated on them for a [ __ ] from new
orleans we got choked up on the beat
and i'm lit we mix that chalk they want
a box i built the coffin take the game
and milk it softly sent the link for
only fans
not gonna work if you gonna cost me get
a bullet from the eagle like a 90 yard
from costume
man i'm so new orleans i should sign a
masterpiece i rep better than ja
rule but when i write a murder inc coppo
why you go so hard
i got people in that bing and they just
caught them in the yard and they didn't
have a shank hold up i've been doing
this rap [ __ ] you little [ __ ] just
started
i was thanking me and grabba leaves with
a dead skin on your caucus
had to switch the [ __ ] up gotta ogre
feel me i'm balling
the smith got fresh prince of the arms
swinging like causing had to pay my
cousin ran with a big part of my great
profits he'll say my heart too big
surprise i ain't got back problems i
just seen the realest [ __ ] who killed
people go red
then same lines go up and down to that
green line go flat
just got that draco so drake ball would
go dummy but i'd rather talk about my
mac man i'm a big fan of the old young
money [ __ ] only fans gonna hold my
money
[Music]
why
[Music]
that's my favorite one that capital
respected so they know they never played
with one i
pray to what goddess cause i came from
an amazing one that's where i get my
cadence from i'm clocking out my
patience the
snapping can represent the flight it's
like a cactus ring speedo don't do so
[Music]
[Music]
i know they won't find a copy cause my
flow is unique is that the reason why
this [ __ ] had a show every week
yo who the greatest imma take your spot
got everything the greatest guy i know i
wanted to code this and that's crazy
because my state is hot to each it's on
i know you don't do the [ __ ] you
speaking on they shouldn't try but they
want to eat the kid they need a green or
chrome hate to draw
knocking off that shoulder that you
leaning on yeah you talk about girls
that you should never [ __ ] leave at
home
double diamondbacks where i'm from we
call that marta flip it then we part
ways i've been the light
[Music]
this world is
[Music]